madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues les conditions
d'utilisation de la voie en site propre
créé sur l'autoroute a10 en essonne
entre villebon sur yvette et la gare de
massy sont actuellement définie par un
arrêté préfectoral du 16 novembre 2010
est cette voie dédiée aux bus vise à
réduire et fiabiliser le temps de
parcours des usagers en leur permettant
de franchir la congestion la plus dure
dans ce secteur l'expérience quotidienne
montre que cet objectif a été atteint
en revanche les conditions d'usagé de
cette voie sont actuellement autorisées
uniquement pour les véhicules assurant
les services de transport public
régulier de personnes organisée par
ile-de-france mobilité ou par les
services du réseau personnes à mobilité
réduite
aussi les navettes privée mise en place
par certaines sociétés notamment thales
air defense fleuron de la technologie
française située à limours communes dont
j'ai été maire pendant 17 ans ces
navettes n'étant pas considéré comme du
transport public ne sont malheureusement
pas autorisés à utiliser cette voie
pourtant disponibles autoriser la
circulation de ses navettes sur cette
voie dédiée de l'autoroute a10 entre
villebon sur yvette et la gare de massy
serait une mesure d'efficacité et de bon
sens qui ne coûterait pas un centime de
plus à qui que ce soit et permettrait un
gain de temps et d'organisation pour
leurs utilisateurs
aussi madame la ministre envisagez-vous
d'ouvrir la circulation on avait deux
privés sur ce tronçon de l'autoroute a10
et plus largement quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour encadrer et
favoriser le développement de services
de mobilité propre sur l'ensemble du
territoire francilien
la parole est à madame elisabeth bord
ministre chargé des transports
dames la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur hugonnet la voie réservée mis
en place en novembre d'une 2017 sur
l'a10 fait partie du programme
prioritaire pour la période 2014-2020 de
réalisation de voies dédiées aux bus et
le cas échéant aux taxis sur le réseau
routier national franciliens d'un
montant de 65 millions d'euros ce
programme vise à hull
encourager l'utilisation des transports
en commun en les rendant plus fiable et
performant et donc plus attractifs il
s'inscrit pleinement dans l'objectif
fixé par le gouvernement
donnant la priorité aux mobilités du
quotidien après la mise en service des
voies réservées darrin d'assises à dadis
et très récemment da 12 en septembre
dernier
ce programme se poursuivra avec la mise
en service prochaine d'une voie réservée
sur l'autoroute a3 et les études de
voies réservées sur la rn 104 et la rn
118 la loi mobilité que je présenterai
au conseil des ministres à la fin du
mois permettra de développer plus avant
ses solutions de mobilité
concernant la voie réservée de la disent
vous avez rappelé les conduit les
conditions actuelles d'utilisation
fixées par l'arrêté préfectoral du 16
novembre 2017
s'agissant de la possibilité pour les
navettes privés organisés par des
entreprises d'utiliser cette voie je
vous informe que votre demande est
actuellement en cours d'instruction
en effet sans attendre l'adoption de la
loi des études et des consultations sont
en cours pour examiner la faisabilité et
l'impact sur les conditions de
circulation qu'aurait une ouverture de
la voie réservée à 10 à l'ensemble des
transports en commun j'examine et
j'examinerai très prochainement avec le
ministre de l'intérieur les résultats de
ces études pour décider du lancement de
cette expérimentation et je ne manquerai
pas de vous en tenir informés